se vi dicessi che esiste una
medicina una medicina in grado di
donarvi salute beness
e forma fisica straordinari che cosa mi
rispondereste
Sì una medicina che può donarvi salute
mentale può migliorare la vostra
autostima può rendervi più
creativi più
felici più
produttivi che cosa mi rispondereste
se potesse eliminare lo stress se
potesse curare ogni forma di depressione
negativa nessuna
controindicazione nessun effetto
collaterale che cosa mi risponderesti
Ah non mi rispondete eh sapete perché
Perché nella vostra testa una medicina
così non può esistere perché per voi
Questa è pura
utopia stavo scherzando ovvio che non
esiste una medicina così una medicina
che potrebbe cambiare le sorti del
pianeta Sarebbe troppo bello per essere
vero Il mio speech finisce qui grazie Ci
vediamo al prossimo
anno ma come mi mandate via
così davvero non siete curiosi di sapere
se esiste una medicina del genere
D'altronde non ne parlano i TG non la
troviamo negli scaffali dei supermercati
né tantomeno Nelle farmacie quindi non
esiste
giusto la risposta non è così
scontata vi racconto una storia da
piccolo avevo un sogno ero
ossessionato con tutto ciò che
riguardava il benessere e la salute
volevo essere
felice Volevo stare bene volevo superare
continuamente i miei limiti fisici e
mentali questo mi ha portato a
ottenere bei risultati a livello fisico
mi ha portato a diventare un manager di
grande successo ma non ero felice avevo
tutto ma mi mancava la cosa più
importante la risposta ad una singola
domanda e Esiste la medicina perfetta
per l'essere umano e se esiste qual è
dov'è ho viaggiato per il
mondo studiando e imparando dai più
influenti medici ricercatori dai
migliori Professionisti del settore ho
passato migliaia di ore su libri studi e
ricerche sono stato il coach di migliaia
di
che si sono affidate a me Ottenendo
risultati eccezionali ma mi mancava
ancora qualcosa la risposta a quella
domanda fu lì che decisi che era
arrivato il
momento di lasciare tutto e di prendermi
un momento di
riflessione avevo un sogno
l'Africa così feci la valigia e partì
direzione Namibia
l'avete mai vista
l'Africa
immaginate negli occhi la luce accecante
del
sole nel
naso la polvere rossa e arida della
savana nelle orecchie il respiro della
vita ogni singolo colore ogni odore ogni
suono era
naturale mi sentivo nella culla della
vita era come se fossi tornato a casa
non lo conoscevo quel
luogo Eppure era così
familiare
Finalmente mi sentivo felice calmo
sereno
centrato ricordo ancora il suo volto
indigeno segnato dal tempo con due occhi
così profondi che hanno attirato
immediatamente la mia attenzione che
cosa ci faceva un abueno in una jeep che
sfrecciava a 100 km orari verso il
deserto del
Kalahari perché una volta arrivati a
destinazione il mio istinto mi ha detto
che dovevo seguire quell'uomo nel suo
villaggio Quell'uomo mi ha condotto al
suo villaggio E così ho vissuto con lui
e la sua gente per 10 giorni li ho
osserv
li ho studiati ho vissuto con loro
esperienze straordinarie ed è lì che ho
capito una cosa molto importante che ha
cambiato profondamente la mia
vita 10 giorni dopo ero tornato a windo
la capitale dell
Namibia ero sotto la doccia di uno
Stello che all'andata mi era sembrato
fatiscente che in quel momento sembrava
un hotel 5 stelle su nonostante gli
scarafaggi che danzavano sulle
lenzuola l'acqua calda della doccia mi
portava via l'ultimo strato di terra
rossa che mi era rimasto addosso e
quello mi creava una forte
nostalgia Io volevo restare lì non
volevo tornare nel mondo moderno Eppure
finalmente ero felice avevo capito quale
fosse la medicina per curare l'essere
umano
moderno ora chiudete gli
occhi fate un respiro
profondo Catapult Datevi nel posto più
bello in assoluto per voi il posto in
cui andreste Se volete sentirvi bene se
volete ricaricarvi di
energia immaginatevi i
suoni i
colori gli
odori ora riaprite gli
occhi qualcuno di voi era in uno yacht
di
lusso eravate in una limousine
nell'attico di un appartamento a New
York
City sono convinto che la maggior parte
di voi era in natura un bosco una
foresta su una spiaggia in
montagna nella
savana questo per
la nostra natura di esseri umani esce
prepotente ci ricorda di cosa abbiamo
davvero bisogno nonostante nel mondo
Moder venga soffocata e repressa e tende
a riportarci in un ambiente familiare
Come era successo a me viviamo in una
società in
cui la vita aumenta sempre di più
l'aspettativa di vita Eppure la qualità
di questa vita è sempre più bassa
viviamo in una
società davvero evoluta abbiamo
conoscenze risorse strumenti mai avuti
nella storia dell'uomo
eppure siamo tra i più ammalati sempre
più persone continuano ad ammalarsi ora
vi faccio una domanda
scomoda Quanti di voi nell'ultimo anno
hanno sofferto di qualche malattia siate
sinceri per alzata di mano potrebbe
essere anche un problema fisico problema
mentale sono entrambi
rilevanti pensate che al mondo un adulto
su 10 ha il diabete 540 milioni di
persone si stima che entro il 2045 si
arriverà a 783
milioni per non parlare delle malattie
cardiovascolari una delle principali
cause di morte al
mondo morivano nel 90 12 milioni di
persone anno scorso ne sono morte più di
20 milioni
l'obesità un miliardo di persone al
mondo è
obeso
34,2 degli italiani in sovrappeso il 12%
è obeso quasi 5 milioni di persone sono
morte prematuramente A causa
dell'obesità ed è una delle principali
cause della maggior parte delle
problematiche e la depressione definita
anche la malattia del secolo 300 milioni
di persone al mondo La prima causa di
disabilità a livello globale non voglio
neanche toccare il tema del cancro e non
basterebbe tutto questo
evento tutto il tempo che abbiamo per
descrivervi la drammaticità della
situazione vivere a contatto con i Bos
shimani mi ha fatto capire ancora di più
che da quando ci siamo allontanati dalla
natura abbiamo iniziato ad ammalarci A
indebolirci abbiamo iniziato a
sviluppare delle malattie che non sono
mai mai esistite nella storia
dell'essere
umano viviamo in un mondo alieno alla
nostra
natura non sappiamo più muoverci Oltre
al fatto che non sappiamo più mangiare e
respirare ci muoviamo sempre meno
trascorriamo 8 10 12 ore al giorno fin
da piccoli
seduti trascorriamo La maggior parte del
nostro tempo davanti a
schermi che emettono luci e radiazioni
dannose per i nostri organismi è come se
non bastasse ci bombardano la mente di
informazioni veramente nocive abbiamo a
tutti gli effetti uno stile di vita da
esseri umani da
Zo ora fatemi un piacere guardatevi i
piedi li
vedete No quelli non non sono i vostri
piedi quelli Quelle sono le vostre
scarpe e non hanno neanche la forma che
dovrebbero avere i vostri piedi anzi
ancora peggio oggi i vostri piedi hanno
preso la forma delle vostre scarpe
Indossiamo calzature che indeboliscono
rovinano compromettono i nostri piedi
uno degli strumenti più importanti per
la nostra libertà di movimento per la
nostra salute per il nostro
benessere e questo
porta a compromettere la nostra postura
il nostro corpo le nostre
menti continuiamo a curare i sintomi
convinti che sia normale essere
ammalati avere dolori vivere con fastidi
e problemi certo per voi è normale Vi
siete
abituati se foste voi Madre
Natura dove mettereste il segreto della
salute e del Benessere dove
nasconder la pietra filosofale in grado
di fornire
l'elisir di lunga vita La Panacea
universale per curare tutti i mali
dell'essere
umano pensateci bene li mettereste
all'esterno del sistema in una sostanza
chimica in una pillola o li mettereste
all'interno
Esatto è proprio lì nel
DNA è nel
codice intrinseca nell'essenza della
creatura uomo pensiamo agli altri
animali l'essenza di un pesce è quella
di poter e saper nuotare l'essenza di un
uccello è quella di poter e saper volare
d'altronde cosa sarebbe un animale senza
la sua capacità di esprimersi attraverso
le proprie forme di locomozione
un uccello che non può volare in natura
non sopravviverebbe così come nessun
altro animale che non può muoversi
Secondo la propria
natura ogni singola cellula ogni singolo
comportamento porta inevitabilmente
l'individuo fin dalla sua nascita a
diventare abile capace e devoto
allo sviluppo della propria natura allo
sviluppo del proprio
movimento nel caso di una gazzella
questo può richiedere qualche minuto nel
caso del cucciolo di uomo qualche anno
di
vita il tutto orientato a portare
quell'essere umano allo sviluppo del suo
Massimo potenziale il tutto
orientato a portare quell'individuo a
sprigionare la sua natura e grazie a
questo a produrre tutto ciò di cui ha
bisogno per stare sano forte e in
salute siamo noi stessi delle vere e
proprie farmacie Abbiamo dimenticato
come attivare i processi
Giusti siamo diventati schiavi di
sostanze esterne quando abbiamo
dimenticato chi
siamo la scintilla per far ripartire il
processo virtuoso è già dentro ognuno di
voi la medicina perfetta è sempre stata
lì davanti ai miei occhi davanti agli
occhi di
tutti dalla gattona alla
camminata dalla camminata alla
corsa che genio questo creatore che Che
potenza Madre Natura ha nascosto La
Panacea nella natura di ogni creatura su
questo
pianeta
pazzesco quando guardavo un uccello
spesso lo invidiavo perché poteva volare
da quando ho realizzato che potevo
correre lì ho iniziato a volare
correre un gesto primordiale
atavico
istintivo unico nel regno animale quando
corriamo si attivano nell'essere umano
dei processi unici a livello mentale a
livello cerebrale a livello meccanico a
livello fisiologico perfino a livello
cellulare non esiste niente di più
di un corpo che
corre
ora lo so che cosa state pensando
correre ma se mi hanno sempre detto che
correre fa male Daniele adesso arrivi tu
e mi dici che la corsa uno sport
demonizzato dalla maggior parte delle
persone è la medicina perfetta per
l'essere
umano Errore
mio mi sono dimenticato di darvi un
dettaglio fondamentale
non è la corsa ad essere così potente
perlomeno non è la corsa intesa come
sport non è la corsa intesa come
attività fisica per bruciare qualche
caloria non è la corsa intesa come
mettere un passo dopo l'altro no non
c'entra
niente non sto parlando di questo io sto
parlando della corsa come gesto
primordiale Come forma di locomozione
dell'essere umano
quando dico che la corsa è una medicina
Non sto usando una metafora è la
verità ogni farmaco per essere efficace
ha bisogno di avere un principio attivo
che funzioni degli eccipienti ed essere
somministrato nei giusti modi tempi e
nelle giuste dosi quindi rispettare una
corretta
posologia
ed è qui che voglio portarvi un cambio
di paradigma
epocale la corsa come medicina perfetta
per l'essere
umano abbiamo una
Panacea di una
potenza assurda a nostra
disposizione ma non sappiamo come
utilizzarla se non corriamo nel modo
corretto
se non corriamo e prima prepariamo il
nostro corpo per farlo viene meno il
principio
attivo ovvio che poi non riuscite a
ottenere tutti i benefici della corsa
non riuscite a godere del potere
salvifico della
corsa ci siamo allontanati dalla nostra
natura oltre che dalla
natura ci siamo dimenticati
chi siamo che cosa siamo e perché
siamo abbiamo dimenticato la nostra
bellezza la nostra potenza il nostro
essere
divini anche il mondo scientifico mi dà
ragione Oramai è confermato che non
esiste farmaco più potente del movimento
e Quale miglior movimento se non quello
che ci ha donato Madre Natura per
spostarci per esprimerci al nostro
Massimo
potenziale ora potete
scegliere potete scegliere di tornare
alla vostra vita
attuale con le vostre attuali
convinzioni
e Fine della storia per voi il mio
speech finisce qui non ho più niente da
dirvi Potete smettere di ascoltarmi se
invece Scegliete di prendere tutto
quello che vi ho detto come sfida
personale ora vi dico che cosa accadrà
falcata dopo
falcata l'ombra e il buio si
dissolveranno
grazie alla
corsa riuscirete a lasciarvi alle spalle
le vostre scelte sbagliate e inizierete
a intraprendere con
coraggio un viaggio verso una profonda
trasformazione come esseri
umani
la corsa Vi aiuterà nel
lavoro nel rapporto con la famiglia vi
manterrà sani e in forma vi donerà nuova
energia
vitale e il vostro esempio potrà salvare
la vita di molte altre persone se tutti
iniziassimo a correre correttamente se
tutti
riscopro la nostra
natura e la potenza di cui il nostro
corpo e la nostra mente sono
capaci Il mondo sarebbe un posto
Decisamente
migliore un luogo in
cui si potrà vivere più a lungo e meglio
in modo più sano e più felice e questa
per me è una possibile
utopia
Grazie
la